[Music]
what's the last time you call the
timeout in your life I'm talking a few
timeout in your life just like they
don't sports when the coach says timeout
timeout timeout
everybody regroups they talk here let's
go back at it and then we'll figure out
to make the play happen and they win the
last thing they call the timeout in your
life when you call it timeout in your
life this means gotta turn off all the
noise parents boyfriend girlfriend's
best friend boss notification snapchat
Facebook Twitter YouTube every single
thing is turned off and you're gonna
place of isolation all by yourself no
one's around and you ask the right
important questions about your life
here's why life's changing every single
second life changes every single second
your president new industry new
technology new something everything
changes but sometimes we stay the same
when you and I stay the same we can
catch up to life life's passing us fine
and in order for you to be able to stay
steady with this we got to call 10 rock
step away and ask yourself the tough
questions am i changing how can I change
how can I improve how can I get better
what do I need to do by myself to have
2017 be better in 2016 but in order to
do that you got to call yourself a
timeout of life we'll call that timeline
it's about that time